[Musik]
60 keine chance
viele von euch wissen ich habe auch
schon bereits auf diesem kanal darüber
gesprochen dass ich ein sehr großes
projekt planen und das mittlerweile auch
umsätze ein damals ich dachte noch es
wäre ein 15.000 euro projekt
mittlerweile habe ich wahrscheinlich so
was wie 25.000 euro reingesteckt eine
menge zeit eine menge arbeit und das
hier ist ein video über die gesamten
dreharbeiten dem zweiten block haben vor
ein paar monaten schon das erste mal
gedreht und von diesem projekt ist
mittlerweile immer noch nichts gekommen
dieses wochenende gehabt aufgrund von
sehr vielen hotelzimmer neben größten
studium mit der größten hohlkehle dass
wir finden konnten einem licht man sehr
viel licht sehr vielen kameras sehr
vielen leuten so was wie 16 17.000 euro
gekostet glaube ich bisher keinen
einzigen cent verdient halt richtig am
rhein buttern aber ich glaube komplett
an die idee und wir machen das halt
super professionell da wirklich an
unsere grenze des möglichen zu kommen
das sogar zu machen wie es geht ein
unfassbares team alles nur leute aus der
community nochmal vielen vielen dank an
jeden der dabei war es war ein
wirkliches fest aber wie sieht das
studio eigentlich wirklich aus wie groß
ist das richtig
eines der ersten studios in dem wir im
match im endspurt zu kürzen was auch
immer drehen werden just in marc gebauer
jana exner viktor braun william vincent
ist kommt eine menge coole leute das
wird auf jeden fall ziemlich ziemlich
neu ist auch das natürlich nicht die
einzigen es geht noch weiter
[Musik]
und wenn wir rausgehen
da gibt es hier noch ein weiteres
studios auf jeden fall ein riesen
komplex und das wird ziemlich ziemlich
kannst nicht wundern diese rolex ist
nicht meine rolex traders ist noch nicht
zu ende ist für ein video dass wir
morgen drehen aber ich habe angst dass
ich sie verliere wenn ich nicht tragen
weil nicht jeder von euch die
möglichkeit hat gerade den eigenen ideen
und eigener projekte zu investieren gibt
es eine möglichkeit über die kostenlose
app um den heutigen sponsor wittmann
super easy in christo und aktien zum ist
selbst wenn das geld nicht reichen
sollte eine komplette apple oder amazon
aktie für mehrere hundert oder sogar
tausend euro zu kaufen schafften wir
wird man nie abriss
es ist nämlich bei wittmann möglichst
schon ab einem cent in crypto oder
aktien investiert das bedeutet jeder von
euch kann sofort anfangen geld zu
investieren selbst wenn man gerade nicht
super viel geld rumfliegen hatte sommer
ist das klima und einfacher designen
helfen aber einen super einfachen
einstieg zu finden und machen ist quasi
jedem möglich sofort investieren aber
warte mal wenn wickelt man jetzt eine
möglichkeit hätte euch geld dafür zu
bezahlen dass ihr geld ausgibt dann
könnte jeder von nicht investieren und
genau das ist erfolg hat nicht nur eine
kostenlose metall karte mit mir mit
bäumen bei der es möglich ist bis zu 15
events gleichzeitig zu nutzen sondern
auch einen cashback system für online
und offline zahlungen bei diensten wie
matt fleck spotify und super vielen
anderen anbietern ist so möglich bis zu
25 der speck zu bekommen bis zu 150 euro
könnt ihr so monatlich direkt zurück
gekommen also ladet euch jetzt die
kostenlose will wird man jetzt über den
ersten in einer video beschreibung
herunter vielen vielen dank dass sie
mich um dieses gesamte projekte
unterstützen nur durch solche partner
ist es möglich dass ich das hier so
mache dass ich die projekte neue umsätze
dass sich freiheiten habe neue sachen
auf youtube auszuprobieren neue sachen
zu machen und eben auch solche sachen zu
machen wie das hier
ich stehe gerade nämlich in der schweiz
und probiere einen viertausender zu
besteigen
das video kommt aber nächste woche jetzt
geht es weiter mit dem studio blog
gäste sind mittlerweile damen zwischen
zwei und sechs soldaten werden jetzt
gleich versuchen den leuten die
richtigen autos zuzuordnen
es steht mittlerweile alles ziemlich
viel licht in die kameras ziemlich viele
leute und ich bin super papa
[Musik]
es gibt nur einen gewinner und das
bühnenbild
erster dreh ist durch mit jana war super
erfolgreich ist so versuch erfolgreich
wir sind leider ein bisschen verzug wir
probieren jetzt gerade ein bisschen zeit
heraus zu holen und dann geht es darum
dass java und victor erraten wer getippt
hat und wer nicht gerade drei leute dort
die tiefen natürlich nicht hier unter
unseren fittichen und dann mit uns zu
treffen ja auch unsere anweisung genau
das mit erraten dann kommen gleich
nochmal und justin die outfits erraten
und die werden auch noch uhren zu ordnen
und in den nächsten tagen geht es mit
super anderen personengruppen weiter
morgen komm rentner und am sonntag geht
es um geld
aber es läuft schon deutlich besser als
beim ersten mal
[Musik]
beim 15 uhr haben vier oder fünf videos
abgedreht und das soll es dann für den
ersten studio block 2 drehtag 1 gewesen
sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
machst du hier lied wenn ich natürlich
zweiter tag sind alle komplett fertig
drehen heute den ganzen tag mit rentnern
das sehr witzig da kann sehr geile
videos aber es ist natürlich für alle
unfassbar anstrengend wir sind riesen
team ist sehr waren gibt wirklich eine
menge zu tun und man merkt jetzt erst
wirklich was für ein aufwand dahinter
steht und die videos sind noch nicht mal
geschnitten also es ist von vorne bis
hinten die planung die umsetzung und die
postproduktion sind unfassbare aufwand
und sind sonst beim arbeiten
interessiert ein krankes projekt und es
lohnt sich ihr könnt euch darauf an das
kommt dem blog gar nicht so richtig
rüber aber wir haben immer nur winzige
fetzen aufgenommen einfach weil es
unfassbar ist wie intensiv wir daran
arbeiten sind also das geht schlag auf
schlag deswegen hat niklas das unfassbar
gut durch geteilt unendlich gut geplant
insgesamt hat niklas für so ein dreh
wochenende wahrscheinlich mit 500 600
leute kontakt und muss dann organisieren
wie viele leute davon wirklich kommen
und die dann dahin lotsen und es ist
einfach ein unheimlich riesiger
organisatorischer aufwand bei dem es nur
den hut zu ziehen gibt vielen dank
nicklas dass wir das alles mit uns
machen aber auch hinter der kamera leo
der hier gerade sitzt und auch bei dem
projekt mit kamera mit mir gemeinsam so
ein bisschen macht wir haben sechs
kameras gleichzeitig manchmal mit vier
und drei kameras parallel in studios
gedreht also ist es wirklich unfassbar
[Musik]
wir sind weiter tag man sieht es mir an
wie es mir geht sehr gut aber ich bin
auch extrem fällig
gerade vorbereitungen für den dritten an
dem wir sehr viele games drehen werden
das morgen wieder mal was komplett
anderes wir drehen einem dunklen studio
mit weniger licht das von oben kommt so
dass ein bisschen julia werte dennoch
wir probiert leute sich gegenseitig
ausstechen zu lassen nicht absprechen
aber aussprechen der sozialste oder der
sympathische wird gewinnen aber das
werdet ihr alles nicht einmal drei
stunden studio glock wiederfinden sind
geladen werden vielleicht auch mal
probieren den leuten die richtigen
outfits zuzuordnen und damit werden
jetzt gleichauf direkt statik ist der
letzte tag wir sind alle super amtes hat
mega gut funktioniert und ihr könnt euch
eine menge content freuen
absoluter traum mit fang an zu bringen
aha
wir sind vom letzten dreh das letzte
video für heute steht an
was das ist dass er daran glaube es sind
alle mittlerweile wieder super pump
haben wieder energie weil es im ende
geht und es im endeffekt doch alles mal
wieder funktioniert wunderbar sind in
der wunderbar funktioniert ohne dass wir
alles wunderbar geplant haben obwohl
einige sehr nützliche mix bord der mit
glas hat alles perfekt geplant aber
natürlich gab es noch ein paar sachen
die einfach unklar waren
[Musik]
das 25 videos gedreht innerhalb von drei
tagen bei denen ich hinter jedem
einzelnen videos stehen kann
der absolute traum das machen zu können
und in super dankbar für jeden der mich
dabei unterstützt hat vor wie hinter den
kulissen und natürlich auch weiterhin
unterstützt und ich freue mich über
jeden der sich das dann anschaut wird
ein fest wenn die ersten sachen hängen
das wird ein absolutes fest der ersten
sachen von das studio werden vermutlich
so mitte juli kommen und ich glaube hier
könnte ich da sehr darauf freuen
mittlerweile dabei waren jana xml justin
viktor brauch willi vincent marc gebauer
niki fritz meine kraft denn sie will mal
denn die unendlich viele leute aus der
community wir haben leute mit krassen
stories da gehabt mit krassen jobs mit
krassen dingen zu erzählen und es sind
sehr witzige sachen passiert ich weiß
gar nicht genau was ich euch alles
erzählen soll weil ich glaube das
projekt wird im endeffekt für sich
darüber sprechen wir legen unser
gesamtes herz unsere gesamte energie da
rein und das wird ein wirklich absolutes
fest ein absolutes reaktion fest für
alle anderen youtuber und die man
natürlich auch das war ein kleiner
einblick wir haben natürlich uns
hauptsächlich darauf fokussiert das
studium möglichst gut zu produzieren und
nicht diesen blog aber es gab zumindest
ein kleines update in kleinen ein weg
wenn es euch gefallen hat was man ja nun
leichter vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren und sie sehen uns die tage
wieder macht's gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]